en francia una ola de calor sin
precedentes se está transformando en una
sequía histórica las terribles
condiciones son evidentes en el canal de
la mancha en el noreste del país que
normalmente se alimenta del cercano lago
llegarme pero la inusual sequía ha
llevado los niveles de agua mínimos
históricos- provocando que el canal se
haya secado por completo se dijo ibm
esto ha sucedido antes pero nunca tan
temprano en el año dependiendo de la
temporada el agua puede subir hasta 50
60 centímetros de altura a veces cuando
es muy lluvioso mucho más así que puedes
ver la diferencia de luís una historia
similar se repite en gran parte del país
por lo que el gobierno francés encendió
las alarmas
la primera ministra elizabeth born
activo un grupo de trabajo de crisis
para coordinar los esfuerzos destinados
a suavizar el golpe de la sequía
histórica la excepcional sequía que
padecemos actualmente está privando de
agua a muchas ciudades y es una tragedia
para nuestros agricultores nuestros
ecosistemas y la biodiversidad esta
sequía es la peor jamás registrada en
nuestro país la situación podría
persistir durante las próximas dos
semanas o agravar y aún más la
declaración se produce después de que se
hayan puesto en marcha restricciones de
agua en casi todos los 96 departamentos
continentales de francia 62 de ellos
están ahora en el nivel más alto de
alerta una clasificación que prohíbe
regar los jardines y la mayoría de los
cultivos el pasado mes de julio fue el
más seco desde 1959 y no habrá tregua
por el momento ya que las temperaturas
superarán los 30 grados la próxima
semana en algunas regiones